as you said you helped make major
strides towards peace in the Middle East
with the Abraham Accords can you
describe what it took to accomplish this
and maybe this will help us understand
what broke down will led to the tragedy
this week yeah so you know I always
believed in foreign policy I I learned
very quickly that the difference between
a political deal and a business deal is
that in a business deal you have a
problem set you come to a concl in usion
and then if you buy or sell something
you either have you know more cash or
you have a company so more to do less to
do political problem set is very
different where you know the conclusion
of a problem set is essentially the
beginning of a new paradigm so when I
would think about how do you how do you
move pieces around the board you
couldn't say let me just solve the
problem you have to think about what
happens the day after the signing and
how do you create a paradigm that has
positivity to it so uh the biggest piece
of what president Trump did during his
uh four years in office was uh he really
strengthened the relationship with
Israel number one and he did things like
uh recognizing Jerusalem as the capital
of of Israel he moved the embassy to
Jerusalem he recognized the goal on
Heights he got out of the Iran deal um
we did an economic conference in Bahrain
where we brought Israelis uh to meet
with you know Sai and emirati and Qatari
businessmen and everyone came together
and and each one of these instances were
Unthinkable previously and everyone said
that if you did it the world was going
to end and every time president Trump
did one the next morning the sun rose
the next evening the sun set and things
moved on and so by doing that what
president Trump did was he he
slaughtered a lot of the Sacred cows of
these these false barriers that people
had erected and showed people that the
vast majority of the people in the
Middle East whether they're Jewish
Muslim Christian whatever religion they
are they just want to live better lives
and so what we basically did was create
a paradigm where the voices for peace
the voices for together now finally had
a forum in where they were able to do it
and we did that in the backdrop the way
we're able to be successful was we
severely limited the resources of Iran
and they were focused more internally
and they couldn't cause the trouble that
they were causing everywhere else since
we've left obviously the Dynamics have
changed but um the the way you get to
peace is obviously number one through
strength and number two by finding a way
for people to be better off tomorrow
than they are today and what I found was
that most of the voices looking for
violence or trouble were people who were
just focused on what happened two years
ago 20 years ago 70 years ago a thousand
years ago people who are trying to so
solve those problems in that context uh
often were we looking more to use those
past grievances as a justification for
their power and for the bad behavior
that they were looking looking to
perpetuate so managing as we have talked
about extensively managing the power
dynamics of the region and providing a
plan this is something you did with the
economic plan titled peace to Prosperity
a vision to improve the lives of the
Palestinian and Israeli people can you
first of all describe what's in the plan
sure so this was something I took on uh
I was working on the political framework
between the Israelis and the
Palestinians and trying to understand
what were the issues and the issues were
were not very many basically was you had
a land dispute so you had to figure out
where do you put borders ultimately uh
you had a security uh Paradigm which I
was much more favorable to Israel's
perspective on uh and obviously the
events of the past 48 Hours have fully
Justified that um that that that bias um
and then uh in addition that you had to
deal with the religious sites but I felt
operationally that wasn't actually as
complicated as people made it because
you wanted to just leave it open for
everybody then I went through and I I
felt that the Palestinian leadership was
fairly disincentivized to make a deal
because there was just this Paradigm
where for they had billions of dollars
coming in from the International
Community and I think that they feared
that if they made a deal they would lose
their relevancy internationally and the
money would stop flowing into the
country so what I tried to do is to say
you know my my Approach when I would get
into a hard problem to say how do I
understand all the different Escape
pches how do I try to eliminate them and
build a golden bridge that becomes
really the the only but also the most
desirable pathway for the uh decision
makers to walk through and it wasn't
always hard and sometimes you have to go
and you know hold their hand or you try
to pick them up and walk them across but
but but a lot of these leaders are very
reluctant to change um and the Dynamics
of the Palestinians also were such that
uh I think they were fairly stuck where
they were so we developed a business
plan for uh Gaza the West Bank uh we
threw in some some uh improvements for
Jordan and Egypt as well I was based it
off of the vision 2030 uh that they did
in Saudi Arabia which I thought was a
Visionary document I went back through
this process and I studied uh basically
every um economic project in the post
World War II period so we looked at what
they did in South Korea why it was
successful with some strong industrial
planning we looked at Japan we looked at
Singapore we looked at Poland why it was
successful we spent a lot of time on the
Ukraine uh plan for the country and why
it wasn't successful and that was mostly
because of governance and Corruption
which actually resembles a lot of what's
gone wrong uh with the Palestinians
where there's no property rights there's
no rule of law and what we did is we
built a plan to show you know it's not
that that hard right in the sense that
between the West Bank and Gaza you had 5
million people and um and we put
together a plan I think it was about $27
billion uh we got together a conference
I had the head of AT&T we had Steve
schwarzman from Blackstone came which
was very gracious of them we had all the
leading Arabic businessmen the leading
Builders leading developers and the
general consensus of that um of that of
that uh of that conference was that this
is very doable you know we think that
for Gau in particular it would cost
maybe maybe seven to to8 billion dollars
to rebuild the entire Place uh we felt
we could reduce the poverty rate in half
we can create over a million jobs there
um the only thing that people said was
holding it back wasn't Israel what was
holding it back was governance and
people wouldn't have confidence
investing there with uh with the rule
that uh that Hamas was was perpetuating
so I encourage people actually to look
at the plan it was very thoughtful it
was 181 Pages we went project by project
uh each project is costed out uh it's a
real plan that could be implemented but
you need the right governance and all of
the different Arabic countries are
willing to fund it the International
Community is willing to fund it because
they've just been throwing so much money
at the Palestinians for years that's
never been outcomes based or conditions
based it's just been you know
entitlement money and unfortunately it
hasn't really achieved any outcomes that
have been successful so it it's a great
business plan it just shows too
rebuilding Gaza you know could be easy
but like I said you know the problem
that's held the Palestinian people back
and that's made their lives terrible uh
in Gaza has not been Israel it's really
been hamas's leadership or lack of
leadership and their desire to focus on
trying to kill Israelis and start war
with Israel Over improving the lives of
the Palestinian people and the current
approach of Hamas the more V vience they
perpetrate the more they can hold on to
power versus improving the lives of
people so they as you said maybe you can
comment on they do not propose an
economics plan I mean Hamas has been
running it now for 16 years um and they
don't have a lot to show for it and you
know our posture with them was basically
a very simple deal you know if you think
about what's the end state in Gaza um
it's actually not that complicated it's
you know there's no territorial disputes
right the bord ERS the Border there's no
religious issues uh there as well you
know you're not dealing with Jerusalem
uh you're basically just dealing with
the fact that um you know Israel wants
to make sure that there's no threat from
Gaza so it's a demilitarization or some
kind of security guarantee um from a
credible Source where Israel doesn't
feel like Gaza can be used to Stage
attacks into Israel or to uh fire
Rockets into Israel and by the way these
are things I was saying you know 3 four
years ago uh that that was the objective
and that was really the fear now that's
been proven you know unfortunately the
fear has has manifested um and in
exchange you can rebuild the place and
you can give the people a much better
life but Hamas has not shown a desire
for that or a capability for that and I
don't think there's enough trust to
allow them to do that which is why you
know under the K circumstances if you do
want to have peace there Hamas has to be
either eliminated or severely degraded
uh in terms of their milit military
capabilities